[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing a theory
surrounding a popular question that has
been posed by fans since the release of
fantastic beasts and where to find them
why didn't harry become an obscurial
let's start with why this question
popped up in the first place well prior
to the introduction of the fantastic
beasts character credence barebone
obscurials had never been mentioned in
the wizarding world of harry potter
before
so what exactly is an obscurial for
those of you who may not know an
obscurial is a young witch or wizard who
is physically or emotionally abused to
the point that they feel the need to
repress their magic and hide their
abilities this repression is directly
related to trauma experienced as a
result of their magic and the
development of hatred fear or shame in
regard to their powers these extremely
negative emotions combined with their
attempt to suppress their magic then
turns into a parasitical force comprised
of dark magic known as an obscurus
obscurials are often young children who
usually don't live past their pre-teen
years throughout the harry potter series
we only ever hear of one witch who could
retrospectively be labeled as an
obscurial ariana dumbledore
the explanation of her illness fits the
description of a witch who developed an
obscurus so it is certainly possible
however nothing has ever been confirmed
by jk rowling or other wizarding world
sources in any case obscurials didn't
become canon until well after the harry
potter series had concluded so i suppose
a rather lame explanation
certainly could be that harry wasn't an
obscurial because the concept hadn't
been created yet however that's no fun
now is it so instead let's put that
thought aside and give this theory a
proper look shall we as i mentioned this
is a question that has been brought up
by many a fan since credence made his
obscurial debut in the 2016 fantastic
beasts film
so it really shouldn't come as a
surprise that jk rowling has indeed
provided reasoning as to why harry never
developed an obscurus directly on her
website jkrowling.com she's answered
this very question under an faq section
an obscurus developed under very
specific conditions trauma associated
with the use of magic internalized
hatred of one's own magic and a
conscious attempt to suppress it the
dursleys were too frightened of magic
ever to acknowledge its existence to
harry
while vernon and petunia had a confused
hope that if they were nasty enough to
harry his strange abilities might
somehow evaporate they never taught him
to be ashamed or afraid of magic even
when he was scolded for making things
happen he didn't make any attempt to
suppress his true nature nor did he ever
imagine that he had the power to do so
all right so let's unpack that in order
to become an obscurial a which or wizard
must experience abuse or trauma that is
associated with magic and from there
suppress their magic for fear of hatred
of their power
the big clue as to why harry never
developed an obscurus then is in the
magic of it all to better understand
let's first take a closer look at the
circumstances of the witches and wizards
who we know or suspect to be obscurials
credence barebone credence was adopted
by an american nomads and second salemer
named mary lou barebone she was a strict
unsympathetic woman who was fanatical
about the eradication of magic from the
world
mary lou openly despised magic and
everything about it hoping that her
involvement in the new salem
philanthropic society would help expose
the wizarding world and ultimately
extinguish it
this of course means that credence would
have grown up in a toxic prejudice
environment in which he would have heard
mary lou preach at length how despicable
it was to be a witch or wizard being
that mary lou was the only mother he'd
ever known it's no wonder that his magic
brought him a sense of shame which we
see in the very way he carries himself
in fantastic beasts
combine this sense of shame with the
physical abuse mary lou would inflict on
credence beating him with his own belt
whenever something odd would happen you
can imagine the profound sense of
humiliation and possible hatred credence
would have harbored towards his magical
abilities a sudanese girl in the first
fantastic beast film news commander
talks of an obscurial a young sudanese
girl of only eight years old whom he
came across in his travels of the
african continent the girls obscurus
developed after she was persecuted by
her entire village for demonstrating
magical abilities
again this persecution would have of
course been extremely traumatic and the
trauma would have been directly
associated with her magic it's not hard
to imagine that being rejected and
mistreated by your entire community
would be enough to make anyone feel
intense shame and hatred for the very
thing that made you different ariana
dumbledore as i mentioned earlier in the
video it has never been confirmed that
ariana dumbledore younger sister of
albus was in fact an obscurial
but the development of an obscurus could
certainly be explained by her trauma and
ensuing illness as you may recall when
she was young girl ariana was viciously
attacked by a group of muggles who
witnessed her doing magic
again this very disturbing event which
was the direct result of ariana
performing magic aligns with rowling's
explanation of how an obscurus develops
so it's very possible that after the
attack ariana could have been so
traumatized that she became resentful of
her abilities
in an effort to never again be targeted
she may have tried to push her power
away
because of course if she hadn't been
performing magic those muggles wouldn't
have known that she was a witch and
never would have attacked her
which brings us back round to our dear
boy harry now don't get me wrong harry
was abused by the dursleys
but for whatever reason when it came to
the dursley's incredibly unjust and
almost illogical mistreatment of harry
he seemed to just roll with the punches
so to speak harry was repeatedly punched
on the nose by his cousin dudley and
treated by his aunt and uncle like a
servant the boy was even made to live in
a cupboard and yet he was a rather
well-adjusted young person who had no
trouble making social connections when
he arrived at hogwarts
so while there certainly was both
emotional and physical abuse harry was
quite resilient to the point that he was
never particularly traumatized
by any one event
sure he wished he could have been raised
in different circumstances but the young
harry that we meet in the philosopher's
stone doesn't seem to be too ashamed of
who he is
far from it he actually seems quite sure
of himself aware that his relatives are
silly and frivolous people
making friends with ron before he even
arrives at hogwarts turning away
alliances with unkind wizards like draco
malfoy and asking the sorting hat not to
place him in slitherin
yes harry potter despite never knowing
who he truly was until the age of 11
seems to know and like himself quite
well
what's more while harry was aware that
strange things would happen around him
as he grew up he never admitted to
himself that these occurrences were the
workings of magic and certainly never
acknowledged that he could be the cause
of these things
in fact harry just muddled his way along
each event often thinking that he simply
had rotten luck
after all he was blamed for unfortunate
accidents all the time
in any case without recognizing that
these strange occurrences were he's
doing he could hardly be ashamed of them
could he how could he try to repress his
abilities if he didn't even realize
there were his abilities
well he couldn't of course
and so if we put all those pieces
together we can see very clearly why
harry never became an obscurial there
was no traumatic event or abuse towards
harry that was explicitly linked to his
magic
as harry was never aware that it was his
magic that led to many punishments from
the dursleys he didn't have the
opportunity to become afraid or ashamed
of his abilities
because harry didn't realize he could
control the strange occurrences he never
tried to suppress his power or hide who
he was because of course he didn't know
himself which brings us to the end of
another video as always i'd love to know
what you think let me know your thoughts
in the comments below and as always if
you enjoyed the video don't forget to
like and subscribe to the channel until
next time there's no such thing as magic
[Music]
you